turning now to Ohio and a hot tempered
debate last night in a tight U.S Senate
race between Democratic Congressman Tim
Ryan and Republican J.D Vance according
to an average of recent polls this is
how close the campaign is Vance has a
small Edge which is three weeks left
until election day we've got our Robert
Costa in Ohio where he's been talking to
voters who are concerned about the
economy uh Bob good morning
Good morning Tony Ohio has long been a
crucial Battleground and this year is no
exception but the senate race is much
much closer than strategists expected
the big question is whether Congressman
Tim Ryan's working class message will be
enough
this just shows how desperate this guy
is for political power I think I struck
a nerve with this guy it was a showdown
last night in one of the nation's
closest Senate races with tense
exchanges on abortion this is not a guy
who's ready to protect the rights of
women my basic view here is that we need
to protect life in this country and on
immigrations you cannot pretend to be a
defender of border security when you
have voted against border wall funding
multiple times this guy has invested
into dozens of companies
that use foreign workers and it has been
Democrats and it has been Republicans
and throughout the race Ryan has cast
himself as an independent voice keeping
President Biden who lost Ohio by eight
percentage points in 2020 at Bay do you
want President Biden to come to Ohio
no I don't you know I want to be the
face of the campaign I want to be the
guy who gives the message delivers the
speeches it's an uphill climb but Ryan
insists he can run his own race
galvanizing voters who are alarmed about
the future of abortion rights and
winning over working-class voters who
went for Donald Trump in 2020. a lot of
people in Ohio are feeling economic pain
what's your message to them in this
closing stretch I get it
see it you know
I understand what you're going through
like I think workers need a tax cut
immediately the only way to help people
early on you know right now in the short
term is is put some more money in their
pocket CBS news's latest polling shows
that nationally views of the economy
have gotten worse amid continuing
inflation and voters are feeling it
personally more now say their own
financial situation is bad and I'm just
tired of the direction the country's
going and I I it's time for a change
things were going so great under the
previous president I don't understand
how Joe Biden won
Trump's endorsement might be enough for
the author of hillbilly elegy says
County GOP chair Jim renacy in Ohio the
Trump endorsement will definitely help
and it's going to be a big key JD's just
got to put that message out there that
he's not a career politician he's
somebody who is from the outside and
that's what Ohioans want to see but
Democrats say some Trump voters remain
in play Trump supporters in the past
just were looking for new leadership
that didn't quite work out very well for
the country at all
Vance who was unavailable for an
interview will rally later this week
with Senators Tim Scott and Tom Cotton
two conservative Trump allies
underscoring how Vance wants that Trump
voter to make sure they come out in
November Gail
all right the clock is ticking thank you
very much Bob